so here I am Tim Ferriss with James Tait
she's going to tell you more about the
Audi r8 which is not available on the
market but we're cruising in it right
now on
1:01 number so James welcome to the show
tell us what makes this car interesting
besides the magnetic suspension maybe
you can start with that and give us a
rundown on what you find interesting in
this car all right well the suspension
has two settings one of which is the
sports setting which is substantially
stiffer than normal setting they're
adjusted by my magnet by electromagnetic
force
the fluid inside the shocks is ferrous
which means it contains iron so when you
want to charge through it it alters how
how stiff the car feels
very cool
where's our 4.2 liter v8 which is
mounted behind our heads
as a time wheel drive 90% of the
distribution goes in the rear and 10%
goes to the front which means it has a
heavy rearward bias which makes it fun
corners you can slide it around still so
you were saying that you actually did
some drifting with this car at Infineon
Raceway were nearby and fan right nearby
I was actually in a parking lot that
Audi had mapped out just the corners
were so tight you could turn the
stability control right off flying into
them and send the tail right around it's
very impressive how despite the weight
being closely in the rear of the car
it's still very stable in those
conditions and that's called mid-engine
in this case yeah this is admitted
very very cool so we'll be playing with
this more today and
hug more to report then until round 2